ces panneaux préfabriqués en bois posés
sur les façades extérieures de
l'immeuble devrait permettre une
économie d'énergie de plus de 300
kilowatts heure par mètre carré chaque
année ce chantier piloté par logirep
c'est un projet d'isolation thermique de
85 logements sociaux sur la ville de
trappes qui s'inscrit dans le cadre de
l'anru le programme de rénovation
urbaine
l'intérêt de ces panneaux c'est dans un
contexte en travaillant au milieu occupé
c'est justement de réduire le temps de
le temps de pose donc de réduire le
temps d'intervention pour les locataires
de réduire les nuisances pour les
locataires et ça permet également comme
il s'agit d'une préfabrication ça permet
de limiter les risques de malfaçons lors
de la pause
trois mois seulement sont nécessaires
pour la pose de ces panneaux
l'anru la région et le conseil
départemental subventium ce projet qui
s'élève à 5 millions 200 mille euros
soit soixante mille euros par logement
l'isolation thermique par l'extérieur va
permettre de consommer moins d'énergie
pour chauffer les logements
qu'est ce qu'on a prévu aussi sur cette
opération c'est mettre des panneaux
solaires pour chauffer une grande partie
de l'eau chaude sanitaire
et puis des panneaux photovoltaïques qui
vont permettre de produire de
l'électricité pour les parties communes
de l'immeuble 229 milles euros seront à
la charge des locataires prélevé à
hauteur de 15 euros par mois sur les
loyers une dépense qui financeront grâce
à l'économie réalisée sur le chauffage
le chantier dont les travaux ont débuté
en janvier 2016 devrait être terminé
début 2017